the One Piece manga finally showed us
the strongest crew in One Piece history
as The Rock crew finally takes the stage
for the very first time in the story on
God Valley at the very same time as a
young Roger with Luffy straw hat and
just wow I mean after so many years of
talking about this Legendary Pirate crew
we're finally seeing them all together
here at God Valley and even though Oda
is still teasing us by not fully showing
Rox dec's full appearance it is still
amazing to see all of these insane
members of his crew including some that
we didn't even expect but before we can
get into any other of these crazy
reveals it does seem like the rox's true
objective here was to obtain these crazy
devil fruits that the celestial dragons
are offering up as prizes for their
really insane and hideous slave hunting
tournaments we can tell because we do
see big mom here almost immediately
going after the devil fruits and capture
what will later be kaidos but of course
it's also very interesting to speculate
about what other fruits could have been
in these treasure chests and of course
we do know that Kuma's fruit was another
of the six but what about the remaining
four and there are actually a few really
fascinating possibilities here based on
other characters that are present at God
Valley for example we never knew for
sure when Whitebeard here ate his Tremor
fruit so I could very easily imagine
that Whitebeard also got his fruit from
one of these prize chests and another
really interesting possibility is is the
float float fruit because in case you
forgot this is the golden line cheeki
here who I think for the first time
actually does something in the official
manga and at some time in the past he
ate this devil fruit which allows him to
make anything float in the air by
touching it including himself then
another random but super exciting option
is that some sort of wind or weather
devil fruit was in there as well because
while Luffy's father monkeyy dragon has
not shown up yet I do wonder if his wind
related Powers could also be related to
one of the devil fruits in these chests
because he should be showing up on God
Valley as well and on top of all that
one fruit that I saw people speculating
about is the naika fruit but honestly I
don't think that the naika fruit is that
strong of a possibility here since the
godo always wanted to get their hands on
it but never have seemed to be able to
nonetheless I even think that there's a
real possibility that rocks already
already has eaten the NAA fruit at this
point since he was able to bring
together such a stupidly powerful crew
very similar to Luffy but even if that's
not the case another very likely option
for one of the treasure chests is of
course the darkness fruit which just
makes perfect sense to be one of the
prizes here I mean it is the ultimate
loia devil fruit and I've even made a
whole theory in the past that rocks was
after the darkness fruit in the first
place plus if you want even more
evidence we already do know that
Blackbeard was greatly influenced by
rocks with his ship name and his goal to
rule the world so would it really make
sense that rocks wanted the darkness
fruit as well but was somehow stopped
from eating it which left Blackbeard to
fulfill that desire later on I mean
there's a lot more to this and it does
make a lot of sense to me at least but
if the devil fruits here weren't
actually rox's true goal let's speculate
then what else might have been well by
looking at the main goal of taking over
the world at least according to soku a
pretty easy straightforward answer here
would be that he just wanted to come out
and wipe out all of the world Nobles
which honestly yeah please do that I
mean the world would be a much better
place without them but if that actually
were to be his real goal here then we
have to ask ourselves once again why
would Roger try to stop him here in fact
they actually do have a short but very
interesting Exchange in this chapter Rox
talking for the first time where Roger
tells Rox to stop something but then Rox
tells Roger to stay out of his way which
honestly is not a lot to go off of but
it clearly shows that Roger knew knew
what Rox was doing and didn't like it
and since we do know that Roger was a
good guy probably at least it's kind of
hard to believe that Rox was doing
anything positive like wanting to free
the slaves but then again all we know
about him comes from sangoku so who
knows and while that's basically all we
got in this chapter for these two
legends the reveal of rox's crew gave us
some truly shocking new information
because out of all of the people in the
world who we have been speculating for
years that they might be on the crew and
I mean who would have guessed Elder nion
who was the Empress of Amazon Lily a few
Generations ago that she was actually
part of this world conquering unbeatable
crew like seriously what what is she
doing here she never kind of gave off
that super powerful Vibe when she let
boa hanok literally throw her out of a
window so did she have some other role
or purpose in the crew or was she just
really playing old lady there I mean
it's pretty easy to imagine that she was
actually in love with someone on This
Crew since that is not only a common
theme for the empresses but she even
mentions that in the story itself but
was it rocks or someone else in the crew
and while we're talking about the former
Empress here this actually makes me
wonder if all the former empresses of
Amazon Lily fell in love with powerful
pirates for example Elda nonion possibly
left someone on rox's crew shaki here
fell in love with Roger's right-hand man
Ry and boa of course is head over heels
for Luffy and there's actually one more
Empress before boa that we aren't
currently aware of but and I mean this
may sound really crazy now but now
actually kind of wondering if it could
be someone even like you know machino
from Luffy's Hometown I mean was she the
missing Empress who seems to be in a
relationship with Shanks here which I do
know I mean it sounds crazy but who else
fits the timeline and is in love with a
super strong pirate well Checkmate
anyways we also got to see the young
appearance of Miss Buckingham who not
surprisingly looks a lot like her clone
Stussy which you know is always funny to
me how some characters somehow shrink
and get super wrinkly with age but to be
fair she definitely has something going
on here with Whitebeard as we even see
her sitting on his shoulders and I mean
who knows this chapter really seems to
suggest that maybe they actually did get
it on and this guy really is Whitebeard
son here and then we have one other
really interesting member here who is
either silver ax or Wang Z and they do
look somewhat like kaido does I guess
there's also Jon who we actually see
chugging down some boost just like we
saw his zombie do on through La bark and
of course we also have a young Shiki who
looks as he did before chopping off his
legs and imple down and man I mean I'm
really wishing that we get to see rocks
because I'm actually kind of worried
that we aren't going to come back to God
Valley for quite some time here maybe
until rogers's flashback or Blackbeard's
flashback it's going to be a while but
before we get more into the future we of
course have to discuss this young Chad
right here Roger in all of his Straw Hat
glory and man I'm getting Goosebumps
just seeing him like this basically
looking like an adult version of Luffy
if we're being honest and of course
joining the fight with him we have his
entire crew including his right-hand man
reallyy as well as his other top
commander scer gaban and then there's
like some other members that we actually
do know the names of and I'm just
excited to finally see all of them in
their prime years I mean clearly they're
going to oppose rocks and his crew but
what else is going on on this island and
in this incident there I bet there is
stuff happening that we just have no
idea yet what's going on there and
actually think that it's pretty likely
as well that the holy Knights might join
into this battle as well and we even met
a few more of them in this chapter like
this one who looks like some sort of
royalty this young woman this gas mask
wearing dude who actually looks a lot
like that orphan back from Big mom's
flashback plus a younger looking girl
with a hat covering her eyes which means
we have have to ask just how strong are
all of these Fighters because I really
want them all to be able to put up a
real fight here and I definitely think
that Garling is a top TI character but
can they really match up with some of
the confirmed strongest characters to
ever live in one piece for now I'm a
little bit skeptical but the battle
isn't complete of course without one
more hero and his Entourage and that's
of course Monkey D GARP who apparently
was on vacation here before being told
by a young Kong who has appeared in the
story in like forever as well that stuff
is about to go down on God Valley and of
course Garb was not about to miss out on
that which honestly this makes me feel a
lot better about garp's role in all of
this because he clearly wasn't already
protecting the celestial dragons at this
really morbid tournament that they're
having here I mean if he was there and
letting that stuff happen it just would
not feel right to me but that's not the
case of course because it does seem like
he's just showing up at the same time as
Roger and Rox and will participate at in
the battle as well in fact it does seem
more likely that this event is what
caused garp's disgust for the celestial
dragons in the first place now one big
question of course is what will happen
after the battle clearly we do know that
Rox was defeated but I do have to wonder
if that is truly the case here now if
you've watched any other one piece
videos you'll probably not that there
are heaps and heaps of theories out
there that rock somehow is still alive
maybe living inside of Blackbeard or
some other shape or form so I do know
I've said this like three times already
but I really can't wait to see what
happens with this battle the devil
fruits and even the slaves here but
speaking of those slaves I don't think
anyone was expecting to see what
happened in this chapter with Kuma and
the rest of the young revolutionaries at
least not this soon because in this
chapter we actually learned that the
three young kids's escape plan was to
actually steal these devil fruits that
the celestial dragons have been offering
as a reward for their Twisted hun
hunting competition and despite all the
insanely powerful Fighters accumulating
on this island the kids basically
succeeded if we're being honest I mean
yeah Ivanov did get stopped in the end
by a young big mom before they could run
away with kaido's dragon fruit and of
course Ivanov isn't winning a fight
against an emperor and she did steal the
fruit from him which confirms what we
were actually told during wano that big
mom did get this particular fruit at God
Valley however that satb back didn't
stop Kuma from stealing and eating the
PW fruit just in time which luckily for
them is the perfect ability to allow all
these three kids to escape so I guess
really good job choosing the right fruit
there Kuma however before they can
actually leave they're confronted by
Saint Saturn here once again shows off
his incredible flames and Authority here
and what we do think is hockey lightning
even in his human form it's really hard
to say what it's supposed to be in this
chapter but seriously I'm thinking more
and more that these goo are not just
supremely powerful even though they're
total stumbs but they might not even be
human in that sense again one thing I
keep saying over and over is that these
might just be straight up Devils or
demons maybe there's something else that
have eaten a human devil fruit kind of
like Chopper I mean there's a lot of
possibilities maybe they are just devil
fruits but I kind of want to believe
it's something cooler and Kuma even kind
of addresses this when he yells at
Saturn that it isn't fair that the world
Nobles are born with such power and
authority but but what's even crazier
maybe is that Kuma says that he would
free people if he had that same power as
Saturn and then Saturn says that that is
exactly why people like him and his
entire race must be erased like
seriously I don't know if these Goro
have just lived so long that they just
think of people as objects or trash but
it's incredible that this is the Goro's
true perspective and really so much for
my old idea that I once had that the
godo might actually be decent people who
kind of try their best to not let emu
destroy the world I mean after
everything we've seen they're just
straight out evil but right after this
Kuma actually uses his new powers to
push himself Ivanov and jinny all the
way to his former home the sorbet
Kingdom which is a bit unbelievable if
you ask me that he was able to be that
accurate pushing across the world
literally moments right after eating
that devil fruit but okay I mean I'll go
along with it because this is a Twist I
personally wasn't expecting at all I
think most people were thinking that the
slaves would spend at at least a few
chapters here but this change is both
super interesting and maybe a little bit
disappointing I mean let me explain
starting with the downside it appears
that this is the end of Kuma's
involvement in God Valley which more
than likely means that we're going to
have to wait even longer to see the real
battle here I mean it makes sense though
that we would continue with Kuma here
since this is after all his flashback
but still I wouldn't really be surprised
if we would have to wait a long time
until a full Roger flashback or
something like that later on to really
see the full scope of this legendary
battle but on the other hand it's of
course not all a disappointment though
because with Kuma now out of the battle
we do have to ask what happened to him
iankov and most importantly jinny
because the three main things that we
know about Kuma's story so far is that
he will at some point need to become the
ruler of their sorbet Kingdom meet up
with Luffy's father Dragon to found the
Revolutionary Army and become a warlord
SLG government puppet plus somewhere in
their is born as well or maybe cloned
we'll talk more about that in just a
minute but I honestly don't know in what
order all of these events will happen in
this chapter it does seem like Kuma and
jinny are going to end up being in some
sort of relationship and living
peacefully in the sorbet Kingdom but
that obviously won't last forever sadly
and actually let's talk a little bit
about jinny though because I personally
am super curious to learn what actually
happened to her in the end but first we
learned that jinny is the reason that
Roger and rocks came to God Valley in
the first place because not only is she
really good at sneaking around but she's
also a genius when it comes to denden
mushies and so with these truly unique
skill sets she was able to transmit the
celestial dragon's location out into the
world which does make me wonder if she
was working for the Pirates all along or
if this was just some sort of really
random transmission that she just got
really lucky the right people hurt but
what's of course even more interesting
from this chapter is that because it
seems that she's settling down with Kuma
she yes is most likely Bonnie's mother
as most of you suggested in the last
video and honestly she has been alive
way longer than I originally thought
like I definitely thought that she would
die at God Valley but we have to ask the
unfortunate question of how and when is
she going to die probably not if cuz
mothers never make it long because
there's no sign that she is alive in the
current story for now though she will
have to be alive a little bit longer at
least luckily until she can have their
baby another really interesting
possibility though is that at some point
Kuma and jinny meet a at that point much
younger Vega Punk and instead of jinny
being a mother Vega Punk actually makes
a clone using her DNA so really who
knows at this point who Bonny is really
we're going to find out and yet with all
of this going on I still get the feeling
that there is so much more to rox's
story than just getting defeated here
during this battle I mean this was
literally the moment that reshaped the
entire one piece world and surely Rox
isn't just going to t out after one
fight right plus he and Roger were both
part of the legendary Declan and there
are just so many crazy theories about
his true goals him living on that
honestly I wouldn't be surprised if
Roger somehow ended up letting him live
if you want to know everything and I
mean everything that we do know so far
about roxc then you can watch this video
right here until then Shanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one